the nation watched the trial over george
floyd death unfold the las vegas mother
wants justice
for the killing of her son back in 2017
tashi farmer was killed
by a metro police officer right outside
of the venetian
trinita brown spoke to jill mohler joe
joins us live on the strip to tell us
what
she is hoping for tonight
natasha's mother's lawsuit against metro
continues this evening now back in 2017
nearly four years ago he was killed
outside of the venetian now
his mother is still waiting for some
sort of justice
it's been very very hard trinidad brown
says she thinks about her son every day
he choked choked the life out of them
and they didn't even care in may of 2017
tashi farmer was chased through the
venetian
tasered and choked to death by metro
officer kenneth lopera
the coroner ruled farmer's death
homicide lopera was never prosecuted
after a grand jury turned down the case
how could she go from this
to diet she says the past four years
have been hard
it's not a nice ride to be on
i just want it all to be over
i don't really know if they're gonna
she would get justice last summer metro
settled with farmer's children for 2.2
million dollars
trinidad was not part of that her
lawsuit against metro and lopero remains
unsettled and is in the ninth circuit
court of appeals
recently watching the murder trial of
george floyd was not easy
had his knee in his neck and i heard
that baby call out for his mom
it just brought back a lot of
i was wondering if how she was calling
for me
ex officer derrick shobin was found
guilty of murdering floyd
it's constant you know
but i'm just happy for his family the
police need to be accountable for what
they do
if it was you and i will be in jail as
the case is ongoing between her and
metro she hopes for
some sort of justice they need to be
punished even more
because they know better
oral arguments for the case are set for
july 7th brown hopes this goes to trial
later this year or early next year
reporting live on the las vegas strip
this evening joe mullen 8 news now